aber es nutzt ja nichts wenn wir eine
bundesverteidigungsministerium wie heißt
sie noch lamprecht glaube ich ja die
also da immer nur erklärt was alles
nicht geht dass man so unglaublich viel
dass ich aber nicht im einzelnen sagen
könne die sich also zur lächerlichen
figur macht wenn sie aus dem bundestag
versucht um gewisse panzer als nicht
panzer zu erklären also rohre die
irgendwohin schießen und woanders
unterkommen das klingt als wäre die frau
auf dem rummelplatz und wird erklären
wie also eine schießbude funktioniert
und es geht hier wirklich um den einsatz
der bundeswehr eine tüchtige der
bundeswehr und militärische hilfe für
ein land im unter überlebenskampf also
solange ich eine solche frau in dieser
situation mit dieser aufgabe betrauen da
ist mir das einfach nicht wichtig genug
da muss ich auf den vorwurf an die ampel
machen anderen scholz an alle so lange
an der frau lamprecht als spitze der
ehemaligen hatte als das
bundesverteidigungsministerium festhält
so lang ist ein eigentlich das nicht so
furchtbar wichtig in welchem zustand die
bundeswehr sich befindet mit welcher
militärischen unterstützung zieht der
ukraine beim überleben helfen kann
[Musik]